You know these Tik Tok videos where each
word lights up as it's spoken? They look
professional, engaging, and they're a
pain to make manually. But I'm going to
teach you a process where you can
automate this entire process. If you can
copy and paste, you can do this. I'm
going to walk you through adding
professional animated captions to your
videos step by step.
Learn how to do these fun captions with
me in this video. Now, we're going to
use two things. One is VS Code and the
other is Cloud Code. Now, VS Code is
just a editor. You can go to VS Code's
website to download. Now, the second
thing is Cloud Code. If you have never
used Cloud Code before, you're welcome
to check out this video here. Make sure
you install Cloud Code properly. And
also you need a paid plan in order to
use cloud code. At the very minimum you
will need to have a pro plan which is
more than enough for the vast majority
of of us and I think it's a great
investment. And the last thing I wanted
to introduce here is Remotion. Now
Remotion is a React package that allows
AI tools to be able to create codebased
videos. Now today our focus is animated
captions. So we're going to go to find a
template and select Tik Tok. Now there
is a demo here. Someone is speaking and
then see this is the animated captions
here. And in this package it allows you
actually to have highlighted words
meaning that as the word is spoken is
being highlighted in a different color.
Now don't get intimidated when I say
different packages coding because we
have AI today. We just need to make sure
that we share with the AI the right
documents so the AI can instantly learn
how to do this for us. Here just copy
this MPX create command. Then let's open
VS Code. And before this make sure you
have a designated folder in your
computer for this project. Then I'm
gonna open that project folder from VS
Code. Okay, I have a folder called Tik
Tok caption demo. And this is my project
folder. I also have terminal window
opened. If you don't have this one
opened by default, you can just go to
view and select terminal to open it.
Another way to quickly install cloud
code is to go to extensions here on the
left hand side. Click on it. Find cloud
code for VS Code. I have already
installed it. It's really
straightforward. You just click install
and it will install it for you. Now, I
have tested the sequence several times.
It's actually better if we download the
right templates from remote first and
then ask cloud code to learn from it.
So, let's just copy and paste MPX create
video at latest and the Tik Tok
template. Hit return. Now, here it's
asking us to create a subfolder called
my video. I'm just going to click return
to accept. Note that there's a my video
folder created here. And at Tailwind
CSS, we're just going to say yes. Click
return. And here, open in VS Code, you
can select Y. Yes, it just creates a new
VS Code window for you. You can also
select in and when you expand the my
video folder, you can see the templates
have been downloaded. All right. Now,
here we're ready to call cloud code.
Let's just type cloud. And the first
step is let's help cloud code understand
our codebase which is the template. And
this is how we do it. slashinit.
This way cloud code will understand
whole codebase and summarize everything
in a cloud MD file for us. Do you want
to make this edit to cloud MD? I'm going
to select the second one to allow all
edits during this session. All right,
it's done its homework. Let's double
check by clicking on the readme.md file.
Perfect. So currently cloud code is on
accept edits on mode. It reminds us we
can use shift plus tab to change the
mode. We can change it once to plan mode
and that just means cloud code won't do
anything until it gets approval from us.
I usually start with the plan mode. So
if we look at the folder right and there
is a public folder. If we expand it
there is a sample video here. It will
save us so much time and cloud code so
much time if we just simply delete this
simple video. We have to drag our on
video to be transcribed into this public
folder. So now I've dragged a lawn test
video which is a long form 16x9
video format. So, even though the
template is called the Tik Tok caption
template, we can actually use it to make
animated captions for long form videos.
Let's see how it goes. Right. So, I'm
just going to type please make Tik Tok
style animated captions for this video.
Use at to find this video. And this is
the simplest single sentence prompt.
Now, clock code has made a plan for us.
is presenting to us. The caption will
feature white text with black stroke
outline. Grain highlight color for
active words. Springbased entrance
animations, word by word highlighting
synchronized to speech timing. Caption
grouping every 1,200 milliseconds. Looks
pretty nice to me. Let's say instead of
green highlight color, I want blue
highlight color. Now I'm just going to
go to no keep planning. This is good.
just changed the highlight color from
green to blue. Now this time I'm just
going to do yes and manually approve
edits. Now I shifted mode to accept
edits. I'm going to select yes and don't
ask again for these similar types of
requests. Now here cloud code realized
it needs to install some missing
dependencies which is quite normal and
all we have to do is like number two to
agree with and this is where cloud code
really shines when it encounters
problems errors it really knows how to
fix it by itself in comparison Gemini
CLI needs a lot of human guidance to be
able to make things work now if it's
your first time running this command do
note that deep down remote package
utilizes whisper locally. So if it's
your first time running the command then
it will take some time to download the
1.5 GBTE whisper model into your local
computer. So it's normal if it takes a
while. All right. Now it says perfect.
I've successfully completed all tasks
and changed highlight color from green
to blue. Generate captions for longtest
using whisper. Now we can see lawn
test.json. This is the caption file and
it's word level. Great. It tells us to
preview the video with Tik Tok style
animated captions. Just do mpm rondev.
Let's just do mpm rondev. Receed.
Looks like some error. And don't worry,
let's just do a screenshot of the whole
thing.
Then let's at this screenshot here and
just say check out this error proof for
it to see the screenshot. See now it
recognizes that it's trying to load
sample video MP4 which is the sample
video we deleted. The composition's
default props are still pointing to the
old sample video. It just means that in
this if you expand src folder the
root.tsx tsx file. We need to update the
source file to the right file name, but
we don't need to worry too much about
it. Cloud code can do it for us. It
tells us it fix it. Let's just go to
local code 3000 again. All right,
let's check it out.
>> Learn how to do these fun captions with
me in this video.
>> Okay, it looks nice. only that we want
this to be a long form video, but it's
giving us a short form instead.
And don't worry, let's go back to clock
code and just tell it this is a long
form video in 16 by9, but it's right now
in short form. Please correct. And
within a few seconds, it tells us it's
done. Oh, nice.
>> Learn how to do these fun captions with
me in this video. So, now we have the 16
by9 long form video, but the captions
are in the middle. Now, you can keep it
like that, but I think it's better to
move it downwards. Let's go back to
Cloud Code and VS Code. It's better, but
the captions should be at the bottom of
the video. Now, it's centered. Okay,
let's check. Cool. This time seems
great. Let's play it.
>> Learn how to do these fun captions with
me in this video.
>> Pretty good. Let's just say, can you
change the highlighted color to pink?
Another two seconds done. Wow.
>> Learn how to do these fun captions with
me in this video.
>> Very nice. Wow. I can't believe it how
simple it is. And if you're happy with
how the animated captions turn out for
you, you can just click render here to
download the video with the captions.
Alternatively, you can also come back to
VS Code and ask cloud code, please
render this video for me. It would take
me hours to animate a video's captions
in this style manually. This is pretty
amazing. Now, I hope you learned how to
do this. If you've run into any
problems, if you have any questions,
please comment down below. And please
like and subscribe if you learned
anything interesting and fun in this
video. See you next time.